Jean-Pierre Pernault vous avez, vous avez été beaucoup critiqué, quelle est la cause euh... (Yann Barthès)
Qu'est-ce que je pourrais faire comme vidéo originale,
mais qui reste fidèle à mon univers ?
( Mais ouais ! )
Let's go !
(ziip)
(Clickk)
(Smakk)
(Dj Khaled !)
(We're  the best music !)
C'est faux
C'est Missak à la prod
Haha !
C'est nos vraies vies à tous
Let's go !
Quand y'a pas d'témoins aux toilettes je me lave quand même les mains, FAUX
Lors d'une soirée Netflix à 2 on voit le film jusqu'à la fin, FAUX
J'ai vraiment lu tous les livres qu'il y'avait dans ma bibliothèque, FAUX
Youtube ça a plus de 10ans maintenant
les médias nous respectent, FAUX
Faire 8 ans d'allemand c'est vraiment super utile dans la vie, FAUX
Quand tu vas en boîte en couple, tu t'amuses vraiment, FAUX
Si j'ai téléchargé Tinder c'est juste pour tester l'appli, FAUX
Faire la blague d'enlever la casquette des gens c'est hyper marrant, FAUX
faux FAUX faux FAUX faux faux faux faux FAUX faux faux faux faux..(Faux X30)
(On va se prendre une dose de bonheur, vous êtes prêts? Tout le monde a la banane, let's go )
Mon jogging me sert à faire du jogging, FAUX
J'remets jamais un caleçon 2 jours de suite, FAUX
J'te donnerais pas le code de mon portable mais j'ai rien à cacher, FAUX
Les meilleurs idées sont celles que j'ai sous weed, FAUX
Quand j'dis qu'c'est la dernière fois qu'je bois c'est bien la dernière fois, FAUX
Si dans tes dm j'te propose un iphone c'est vraiment moi, FAUX
J'te l'offrirais plus tard ton cadeau d'anniv, FAUX
Quand t'es l'seul à avoir l'permis tu deviens taxis
A ça par contre c'est vrai !
faux FAUX faux FAUX faux faux faux faux faux FAUX faux faux (Faux X30)
(faut arrêter de se mentir à sois-même )
I got it
(Incompréhensible)
Le débat chocolatine/pain au chocolat est passionnant, FAUX
Pour faire les bébésn papa met une petite graine dans maman FAUX !
Les végans parlent souvent d'autres choses que du fait d'être végan, FAUX
La photo du burger et celui servi sont ressemblants, FAUX
La première fois s'est vraiment passée comme tu l'imaginais, FAUX
Depuis qu't'es en couple t'as clairement arrêter de te m**turber, FAUX
Si tu t'mets au fond d'la classe c'est parce c'que tu vois mieux de loin, FAUX
T'es capable de citer une chanson du groupe dont tu portes le t-shirt
et c'est quoi l'groupe sur ton t-shirt ?
Ah tu connais aps ? heu...c'est les Ramonès c'est assez fucktup, ils ont fait quoi, ils ont fait... heu...
Smells Like Teen Spirit (Nirvana). FAUX
Quand j'étais petit j'étais un enfant à problèmes
Je n'avais pas beaucoup d'amis
je me suis réfugié dans mon univeeeeers
C'est faux, j'étais un mec normal en fait, hinhin (rire) yees
Faux FAUX faux FAUX faux faux faux faux FAUX faux faux (Faux X30)
Dalila lalila lâchez vos abonnements
haha j'ai envie de rigoler putain !
Cette chanson elle est trop marrante !
Yes ! Ok !
Lâchez un pouce en l'air !
Lâchez un thumb to the top
FFAAUUXX
Thanks for watching, heu traduction : Merci pour le visionnage
Montrez moi votre puissance en lâchant un gros pouce en l'air à cette vidéo, thumb to the top !
aur'voir !